There's really no other way to introduce this
next clip other than to tell you that when
asked about the exploding corona virus pandemic
in the United States yesterday, Donald Trump
said Obama and Biden stopped testing.
We're going to try to figure out what he meant.
But this is a man who is disintegrating.
This is a man who has collapsed.
This is a man who really has nothing that
he can say because he has so mishandled coronavirus
that he's just muttering the name of his predecessor
at this point.
And is this another brain glitch?
Is this Trump trying to come up with some
new excuse as to why he failed on the virus?
And, you know, we've joked that Donald Trump
is going to blame Obama for his coronavirus
failures.
And he sort of has.
You know, when Trump says the cupboards were
bare, that he means we didn't have ventilators
or PPE when Trump became president.
Now, of course, that's not true.
But it's a weird critique because Trump had
three years of presidency before Corona virus
hit during which he could
have refilled those cupboards.
But putting that aside, in this clip, Trump
is asked by CBS News reporter and friend of
the David Pakman show, Wadia Yang, asked about
the cases exploding.
And Trump looks terrible and he says, well,
Obama and Biden stopped testing.
Take a look.
You've said many times that the number of
coronavirus cases is going up because testing
is increasing.
Right.
Do you acknowledge that it's going up for
other reasons to, for example, that it's actually
spreading?
And what are you going to do to stop the spread?
Well, you know that we have one of the lowest
mortality rates anywhere.
If you know a Biden and Obama stopped their
testing, they just stopped it.
You probably know that.
I'm sure you don't want to report it, but
they stop testing right in the middle.
They just want no more testing and on a much
lesser problem than the problem that we have.
Obviously, with respect to this is the worst
thing that's happened since probably 1970.
And this is very bad all over the world's
188 countries right now.
Biden and Obama stopped their testing.
What is he talking about in the middle of
what?
Like what what is he actually referring to?
Did Trump mean to say that?
Was it some kind of mental glitch?
And I've been trying to be as charitable as
possible.
Like, what does he mean that Obama and Biden
stopped Ebola testing in 2014?
That's when we had four cases and two deaths.
The Ebola pandemic in the United States.
It wasn't even a pandemic globally, but it
was an outbreak in the U.S.
It was four cases and two deaths.
Is that what he's talking about?
Obama and Biden stopped testing for something
we had four cases of.
Was he maybe referring to H1N1, which, of
course, was dramatically different and everything
about that?
Like, what is Trump talking about?
And in fact, yesterday he was particularly
incoherent during this event.
Here he is repeating.
They are buying.
They are buying over and over again just another
futile attempt by Donald Trump to use language
in a phrase, one deal still intact.
Or is it?
Do you see it exists intact?
It's intact.
But, um, I think what China has done to the
world with what took place, the China plague,
you can go at the China virus, you can call
it whatever you want to call it, about 20
different names.
What they did to the world should not be forgotten,
but it's intact.
They're buying whether they buy or not.
That's up to them.
They're buying very sloppy.
And, you know, I we said before, when Trump
aced the Montreal cognitive assessment that
it's no big deal in watching this video.
I'm questioning whether he really could ace
it.
I mean, this is a very damaged individual
here.
Does.
Does Trump know what city he's in when he's
answering these questions?
Because this is bizarre behavior.
It can't be allowed to continue and it might
unless we all get out and vote.
And that's what I need to talk to you about
next.